(mouse clicking)
(digital beeping)
(upbeat piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(bright digital keyboard music)
(upbeat electronic music)
- First question is from Marcus.
Nature recently published a claim
that humans lived here in
San Diego 130,000 years ago.
Is there any
genetic evidence to
support that inference?
- To my knowledge there is none.
Where the evidence is,
is that,
there were civilizations
within the Americas, probably,
up to about 16,000 before now,
not very much earlier than that,
that those people probably
came on a coastal route,
from the north, but
there is a lot of debate
among the Americanologists
about the age at which
the first settlements in
South America occurred,
relative to say, Kennecott
Man and Clovis Man,
which are in the 10 to
13,000 years before now,
but unlike what happened in Europe,
or in the Russian area
where Denisovan Man,
or Denisovans were discovered,
there is no evidence of any introgression,
which is sort of a sophisticated
word for hybridization
with any other people,
Neanderthals probably
hybridized to some extent
with modern humans and Denisovan DNA
which comes from the
Southern Russian area,
it is found throughout the oceanic area,
from Southeast Asia towards New Guinea,
whereas that DNA doesn't seem
to appear in the European area,
on the other hand the Neanderthal DNA
does appear through everywhere
in the western hemisphere,
except Africa, where there is no evidence
that there was any hybridization.
So that's a sort of a
two-minute history of that.
- Before you leave,
I have just received this question,
could the out of Africa
model be overturned some day?
- I think it's, did everybody hear that?
It said can the out of Africa
model be overturned one day.
I think it's highly unlikely,
there was what was called
the multi-regional hypothesis
before people started to get significant
amounts of genetic
information from Africans
and compare it to the variation
that existed in the rest of the world,
there was this hypothesis
from Walpart in Michigan.
- Walpart.
- Walpart, yeah,
that humans, hominids evolved several
times in different places,
and I think that hypothesis
has pretty much gone by the board now,
and acceptance by most paleo archeologists
is that modern humans exited from Africa,
whereas probably Homo
Erectus exited a lot earlier,
so what we talk about,
about out of Africa,
what I was talking about is
called out of Africa two,
and out of Africa one is Erectus.
- Exactly, and before you leave,
a lot of people present
this as an either or,
paleontology versus
molecular data, high five.
Both lines of evidence.
Now we turn to monkeys.
Dorothy, is there much theft
of nuts by dominant monkeys,
or is there sharing between
even unrelated monkeys,
I ask this as you note the cohesive nature
of your study group in Brazil.
- Okay so let's see,
there's two questions,
do the dominant steal, and is
there sharing among unrelated,
Right, those are the two?
So dominants don't steal nuts,
but they do displace lower ranking
individuals at anvil sites,
so the competition that we've seen
is not about the nut per se,
but about access to the anvil,
and particularly access
to that hammer stone,
the hammer stone is the most uncommon,
or the least available resource,
the most valuable resource
because it's rare.
So I did once see
a young juvenile steal a nut
that his mother had cracked,
but that's a different kind of theft,
and his mother was annoyed,
but nothing much came of it.
That could be familiar too.
(audience laughs)
Let's see the other question was
Sharing and among unrelated.
So capuchins are quite tolerant
towards young individuals,
adult capuchins are quite tolerant
up to around, somewhere
around two or two and a half,
and it's quite common for
an adult to crack a nut,
or to be busy cracking nuts,
they're often doing this for a while,
and there's more than
one nut that's cracked,
and for a whole crowd of
juveniles to be clustered around,
the pictures I showed often
showed one or two juveniles,
sometimes it's three or four,
and they are often sitting so close
to the adult that is cracking,
that you have the idea that maybe
they are gonna get cracked too,
they don't seem to,
but they really crowd in closely,
and the adult just keeps
on doing what it's doing,
and the young ones are right there,
and it is not frequent,
but we have seen an adult allow juveniles
to simply take nuts from their hands,
we don't see active giving,
I saw that once in 15 years of watching,
I don't know how many
thousands of bouts of cracking,
and some individuals are more tolerant
towards the young ones than others,
and they're kind of preferred
partners for the young ones,
they kind of hang around
with the nice guys,
and they are frequently scrounging
at anvil sites when an
adult has finished and left,
then there's all kinds of
debris and remains there,
and that's very attractive
to the young ones and they go there,
so there's a lot of you can call it,
post prandial sharing that happens
at the anvil in this way,
and a degree of relatedness
is not particularly important in this,
in the first place if it's a male
we aren't certain of
paternity in any case,
and if it's a female,
she doesn't seem to mind
if it's her own offspring,
but typically it is closer relatives
when it's the female that's cracking.
- Thank you very much, next
question is for Dietrich,
and as he comes up here I'll add to it,
we all saw that picture of the chimpanzee,
and it was not doing very
well at making stone tools,
and it didn't have pants.
How can we suggest evolutionary
progression of human technology
when Neolithic technology
appears cross culturally
and independently across time?
I can repeat that if you need a minute.
How can we suggest
evolutionary progression
of human technology when
the Neolithic technology
appears cross culturally and
independently across time?
- Well I don't think I know
a lot about the Neolithic,
but I wouldn't probably
want to characterize
there being one unitary
Neolithic technology,
and I also would hesitate
to use the word progress
in really any kind of evolution,
but in terms of technological evolution,
I think what we see is really
a diversification in the
paleolithic time period,
where you have older
technologies sticking around,
but newer technologies being
added in some places to that.
Certainly there's a lot of
potential for reinvention,
again I don't know much about Neolithic,
but for instance the hand
taxes that I was talking about,
particularly the earlier ones,
the early esculapian,
I think it's not unreasonable
to think that that tool
was invented many times,
a lot of people think that explains
some of the geographic
patterning that we do see.
So I think this cultural accumulation
and diversification is not
at all incompatible with
multiple reinventions.
- Thank you.
My next question indicates
that the voles and opossums were big hits.
This one's for Leah.
It actually is the outline
of a long-term research project for you,
so do voles breed fast enough,
that you could follow multiple
generations of blind voles,
to see if any permanent evolution
of brain organization
had occurred over time?
- I'm not certain I
understand the question, so?
- I think what they're asking is,
can you look at the abolition
of the brain in blind voles
by having multiple generations
in your laboratory,
given that we all are here on this planet
for only about a hundred years.
- Okay, so I'll say two things,
one is that this might
relate to your question,
there's actually a natural experiment
of naturally relatively blind animals,
they're called blind mole rats,
and I took them out of my talk,
because I thought I wasn't
gonna have enough time,
but it turns out if you have animals
that are naturally blind,
you have skin growing over their eyes,
and their eyes get an ophthalmic,
really, really tiny,
and they only use their visual
system for circadian functions,
night and day, and not object recognition,
it turns out that if you
look at their neocortex,
it looks a lot like the
bilateral nucleate voles
that we made, you can't
get rid of the one,
but it gets functionally
re-specified to become auditory.
In terms of voles,
I'm not thinking they breed fast enough,
but I think a related question would be,
what would happen if you looked
at the experimentally blind
monadelphous that we made,
and have their mothers reproduce,
and consistently have the
monadelphous be blind,
so you're now rearing
this culture of blindness,
I think you'd probably
see some differences,
then just the sort of
things that we described,
so I think that might kind
of answer the question,
or am I just like blah.
- Probably how many generations
of that would you have to run?
- I don't think it would take very many,
because I will say we did rear
our blind animals in a
highly enriched environment,
so we said can we take this
natural somatosensory plasticity
and amplify and direct it
by rearing these animals
in a large cage with lots of
different tactical textures,
and we were able to change
neural response properties,
we were able to change connectivity,
we were able to change behavior,
so that you can actually manipulate things
beyond just removing sensory activity,
but changing the environment even further.
- Very good thank you,
finally for John Shea,
I see different people using
a variable amount of tools,
my sister carries tools and uses them,
I rarely reach for tools,
we are the same species
doing different things,
would your scheme classify us differently?
- No.
(audience laughs)
- Perfect, and I have a follow-up,
it's not exactly a follow-up.
Why is fire not considered a tool,
where does mastery of fire fit
in the history of technology,
and what impact did it have on
pre-human brain development.
- That's a bit outside
of my area of expertise,
I can make fire,
I enjoy making fire,
but I'm not an expert on the
development of Pyro technology,
the earliest claimed evidence of fire
are between one and a half million
to a little under one million years ago,
I think the evidence grows stronger
in more recent contexts,
it's a tool,
it's a physical process,
but we have such tenuous
and fragile remains of fire,
it's not as amendable to
describing its variability
in terms of the traces that remain,
for example, one can
make fire by collision,
flint and steel,
friction,
several different kinds of friction,
using a lens,
how you could discriminate
those various complex
different ways of making fire,
simply by a pile of carbon stained soil,
is an unsolvable problem at present.
How early humans made fire
is one of the big unanswered questions,
I truly regret I can't give you
a straightforward answer for that.
- More research to be done,
and with that I'll turn it over to Pat,
who has now organized the
questions from the second session.
- So will start with Paula
who was the first speaker,
and Paula the question is,
are there a disproportional number
of dyslexics among English speakers,
given that English was suggested
as being especially problematic?
- The answer to that is yes,
the more transparent a language is,
the easier it is to learn to read,
and the fewer people
struggle to learn to read,
so languages like Spanish or Latin,
where one sound one letter,
you have a lot less problems learning it,
and we're not only talking about dyslexia,
we're talking about learning
it as a second language as well.
- And a related question for you,
do dyslexics have impairment
concerning numbers and mathematics?
- Well it's really interesting,
all academic achievement in the end
is highly related to
your language ability,
because 80% of whats taught in schools
is taught by spoken
language, oral language,
not written language,
and there are children of course
who are quite good at mathematics
who still are really
struggling with reading,
so I'm kind of answering
it into different ways,
if you improve children's
language ability,
let's say children who are struggling,
in both spoken and written language,
their math scores go up comparably,
so I think we have to
think about math in terms
of what you have to say inside
your head verbally as well,
as just the symbolic numbers.
- I may want to ask a question,
I'm probably not supposed to,
so I'll just block out there.
The question I have is this,
that a number of years ago you showed
this really kind of amazing thing,
which is that a subset of dyslexics
who were otherwise
cognitively quite normal,
have limitations on the
processing of auditory signals,
such that it's very difficult
for them when they are acquiring,
forget about reading,
when they are acquiring a language,
hearing,
it's difficult for them to
distinguish between pa and ba,
and so they grow up calling
a poplar tree a popular tree,
and so when Paula suggested this,
she had a wonderful experiment to show it,
and it was that children
who were diagnosed
as having slow language milestones,
or being dyslexic,
but who are otherwise cognitively normal,
couldn't distinguish between
these very fast transience,
beep boop, boop beep,
They couldn't do it,
they didn't know in which
one the low came first,
and that strikes me as
being a remarkable thing,
and what I think is kind of
interesting in this context,
where we are thinking about evolution,
is the question, if once
language was such a thing,
and such an important social tool,
you would think if the genetic folks,
those who see genetic changes
all over the place in modern humans,
you would think that that
would be selected against,
and that over a few generations,
dyslexia,
or at least not being able
to distinguish between,
beep boop, boop beep,
would be selected against,
and yet it's not.
This is just partly a reflection,
I'm sorry I don't really want to go on,
but it's partly a reflection
of the worry in general that I have,
which of course is related
to those humans on the East Coast,
who want to see genetic changes
and innateness for everything practically,
and so I'm just slightly cautious,
so I'll bring that to a halt,
but I'll just ask you,
don't you think it would
have been selected against?
- Okay, I've got to start with one thing,
and that is a lot of people wonder
what's the relationship
between the sound and reading,
because a lot of people think dyslexia,
is something to do with
seeing things backwards,
it's been pretty much an old wives tale,
but it's still in the public
view what dyslexia is about.
In fact in order to become
a proficient reader,
you have to become aware that words
can be broken down into
smaller units of sound,
and it's those sounds that
the letters represent,
so if you're having difficulty in reading,
most scientists around the
world have demonstrated
that difficulty for
about 80 to 90% of kids
comes down to auditory processing
of the type you're talking about.
It's a long story to answer it,
some people feel that
individuals who are dyslexic
actually have talents in other areas,
particularly in the visual spatial domain,
and that they're not selected against
if you want to think of it that way,
because they're bringing
other things to the table,
but when you look at those
little kids that are struggling,
it's a pretty tough road for a long time,
and one of the things I
often have said to parents
who are so concerned about their children,
if we had a different outcome of interest,
the violin playing rather than reading,
we'd have a whole different
group of impaired children,
so it's a cultural thing
that reading has become so important.
- Thank you and I apologize
for sort of abusing my privilege.
I think we are on to
Raphael at this point,
so Raphael,
what is your take on mathematical
ability being genetically selected for,
I think you did kind of
summarize that at the end,
but you might like to do that again,
like the Malcolm Gladwell theory
of South Indian rice
farmers being better at math
because of selection for farmers
with better geometrical skills,
and I think Harbending,
who's a geneticist,
said something about Ashkenazi Jews
being better at mathematics,
because they weren't
allowed certain other jobs,
and so they had to be accountants.
So I wondered if you might
want to address that?
- Well in my talk I was trying
to show that mathematics
is a cultural trait invented
for very specific needs
and so on and so forth,
also mathematics is multi faceted,
it's not just about number
crunching arithmetic,
it's about logic,
spatial relations,
and many other things,
and then of course we
have to make a distinction
between school mathematics,
and let's say more formal mathematics,
and so here the question would be,
which one are we talking about.
So clearly if you have a
culture that deals let's say,
because of arts and crafts,
and dealing with making
things with their hands
and weaving et cetera, et cetera,
you're going to have some
kind of spatial capacities
for putting things together,
but that in itself is not mathematics.
Now if you put those people
in some sort of environment
where there's going to be
let's say numerical relations,
or counting or doing things with space,
maybe they are going to have
an advantage that's for sure.
- And another question,
this has to do with learning
disabilities and mathematics,
where people may have limitations
on doing any form of arithmetic,
although they may be cognitively
quite normal in other domains,
so they might be able to
recognize the number six,
but if you said that
this banana cost $600,000
that wouldn't make any difference,
whether you said that
you said it was $0.60.
Do you know anything about the circuitry
that is impaired in those kinds of cases?
- That's not my domain of research,
but I would say again,
I personally don't want
to reduce mathematics to number-crunching,
so an accountant is not a mathematician,
they do a lot of number-crunching.
So it could be that
there are certain things
that are impaired because of that,
but learning disabilities could
occur at many different levels,
you could have mathematicians
who are actually awful
at doing the percentages for
the tip in the restaurant,
oh you're a mathematician,
oh my god, terrible.
There are math books
that don't have numbers,
because it's not necessarily about,
the fruit or the juice of
math is about other things,
so number happens to be the cornerstone
for bringing math to being,
but then you could have people
who are not very good at number-crunching,
but being amazing logicians,
or mathematician in that sense,
so mathematics is so multifaceted
that we can't just say this is it,
this is the math team.
- So multifaceted in the way
that being an athlete is multifaceted,
you might be a great football player,
but a poor snowboarder.
- Sure, exactly, there's
certain body morphologies,
that are more appropriate
for certain kind of sports,
so if you want to play in
the NBA and you're 5'2",
well it's not gonna work very well,
same thing if you wanna do snowboarding
and you don't have good balance,
then it's not gonna work either.
- Okay, so now we are
moving on to Candice,
and the question is,
how iPhones and iPads affect children's
brains during very early development,
like between birth and
say, four years old,
and the second question is
don't they need to get bored
in order to explore and enhance
their creativity and
cognitive development?
- So I think the question of very early,
I work with adolescents,
but many of the fears are the same,
the American Academy of
Pediatrics has a standing
hour limit that they've
placed for young children,
and that hour limit,
first it was an hour,
most recently it was two hours,
but what they'd look at with kids,
what they were actually
doing was four or five hours,
and what they've done,
is they've modified it for
families to make a family plan,
what fits with your family,
each family is gonna be different,
and time in front of the screen
is gonna be very different,
if it's with a child, mum, or caregiver,
reading with the child and
interacting with the child,
if that app is high quality,
looking at puzzle making or something,
or just passive viewing on
YouTube or something like that.
So I think the idea,
no one is recommending
that a young baby is put
in front of a screen for
a long period of time,
that's not what we're talking about,
but the idea that we could
place some arbitrary number
on screen time without
considering how it's scaffolded,
or how children are introduced,
or how technology is integrated
into the home is difficult.
- Don't go away.
I think this pertains to
some comments in the
earlier part of your talk,
so the question goes like this,
if mental health is culturally
defined and self identified,
that's a bit of an if I think,
how can we separate
the child's correlation
of digital technology and material health,
these may influence
their personal happiness,
I guess this has to do
with the reliability of their reports,
this may influence them to try
to get away with what they want.
- So the question might be,
we don't see this association
between reported screen time,
whether it's by the child
or maybe by an adult in mental health,
and maybe that's due to
some error in reporting,
so there are other ways to measure it,
you can do a digital device logs,
so you can actually track the amount
of time the kids are online,
you can use other metrics,
so in many of our studies
we actually get cognitive
tested performance,
we administer them in the home,
for example we have a paper coming out
showing no association
between digital technology use
and cognitive performance
based on end of grade testing,
or tests that we administer in the home,
except that these very extremes,
and when we find those we
can get rid of those effects,
if we take into consideration
how much material
resources the family has.
So what we might be observing when we see
these negative associations
between kids online a lot,
and poor outcomes across
a whole lot of domains,
there's a whole lot of
other stuff happening
in that house with that
kid in that family,
and sometimes it's just
not about the phone.
- Okay, I think that we've got it,
and now Joe Henrik,
now Joe, you're kind of in trouble here,
because you've got about five questions,
so prepare yourself.
Okay, how do you explain the
success of insular communities,
and their technological success,
and if I may just elaborate
for this question,
the Inuit for example live in
these tiny little villages,
and they have invented the
most remarkable devices,
including remarkable clothes
and boats and dogs and on and on,
so is that something you can address?
- Yes,
I think it's Chapter 13,
no 11.
- Okay that's done then.
- Can I just say a few more words on that,
just in case people
haven't got the book yet.
So if you look at the
details of the ethnography,
from either groups in Australia,
or groups like the Inuit,
they often have elaborate
cultural technology social norms
which interconnects these
otherwise disparate groups.
So things like seal partners,
so you will have certain individuals
which are gonna share seal meat,
So when you find a seal you got
it eventually go find your partner,
which could be a long trek,
then you get to interact
in their community.
Other kinds of long-distance relationships
keep these lines of communication open.
We know from the trading
networks in the Inuit
that they were all interconnected,
and in fact the languages
were very similar.
What seems to have happened
prior to the Inuit,
was a group called the Dorset
had previously spread
across the Canadian Arctic,
and they had more complex technology,
but then over time,
they broke apart and they
became more technologically isolated,
and then they lost bows and arrows,
which was a big trouble for them
when the Inuit arrived
with bows and arrows.
And another example from
Australia is linguistic exogamy
so you have to marry someone
who speaks a different language from you,
that creates a marriage bond
between other communities,
there's also communal rituals.
- That's great,
do you want to say a little bit more
about the spices that we can
use for antimicrobial effects?
- So I recommend, the paper
is by Paul Sherman and Jennifer Billings,
and they actually rank the
spices according to the number
of different bacteria
species that they kill,
the top ones are the ones you'd guess,
garlic, onions, chilis are up there,
they get about 75%
of the bacteria they've tested against.
And then the really powerful
ones are these combinations
like chili powder, which has
several different spices,
I think 13 different spices in it.
- Okay we'll look for those.
So then the observation is that there are
of course these wonderful
social insects like termites
who have a kind of collective brain,
so is there a strong or a weak analogy
between the collective brain
for hominids that you are thinking about,
and the collective brain for termites?
- So I think the best work on
this is by a biologist named Tom Seeley,
and he has a book called
Wisdom of the Hive,
and he actually discusses how
bees make communal decisions,
by all the bees go out
to their different areas
and they come back together,
and they can do these waggle dances
which is a way of
aggregating the information,
until one signal wins out,
and then they all go that way.
So there are parallel
patterns in other species,
where information is aggregated,
and the group functions as
a kind of collective brain.
In the case of humans,
ours is just a more powerful system,
because with cultural learning
we can communicate
so many different kinds of information.
- Okay, and what were the genetic changes
that occurred about two
million years ago such
that hominids gathered
in larger groups that
made all of this happen?
- So the case that I make in
The Secret of Our Success,
is that the changes weren't genetic,
so I don't like genetic
magic bullet explanations,
so I proposed one thing
is that there was a larger predator guild,
and one of the ways mammals
respond to more predators,
is they cluster in larger groups,
so if we had a Savannah bipedal ape,
it would cluster in larger group,
with a larger predator guild.
At the same time the environmental
fluctuations began to increase,
so we now know this from
these deep lake cores,
that showed you were
getting more fluctuation,
and theoretical work done
by Rob Boyd and Pete Richardson,
indicates that we should expect
more reliance on social learning
when you see the environmental change.
So those are two key factors
that don't have anything to do with genes
That would have meant that primates
were more likely to cross.
And there was a bunch
of different species of Australophocaena,
so there are a lot of
natural experiments going on,
and the idea is that one of them crossed.
- Okay, and the last question I guess,
is human evolution accelerating,
I don't know, yeah.
- Well the one thing we do know,
is that since the origins of agriculture,
there's been a whole new
suite of selection pressures
and populations have gotten a lot bigger,
so if you have larger populations
you have more chance for mutations,
more chance to find beneficial mutations
and then adapt to all these
new selection pressures,
which include new disease environments,
new kinds of food,
the spread of dairy,
so there's been a lot of
genetic change in our species,
and some population biologist
have argued indeed that
it is accelerating.
- If I may just take the
liberty of following that up,
so correct me on this,
because I'm sure I'm wrong,
the geneticists tend to say
that the main genetic changes
really pertain to things
like digestive enzymes
like lactase,
and two features of the immune system,
and finally to things like eye color
and skin color and hair
texture and so forth,
but so far at least,
they don't see anything that
you might call a genetic change
For greater sociality,
or for greater niceness.
Or for, yeah.
- Right, so my reading
of the literature is the same as yours.
- Oh, okay.
- Although I would say things
like lactose genes to change behavior,
so if you can process
lactose then you drink milk,
and that gives you a whole
new set of possibilities.
Things like genes that increase
your ability to process
alcohol can change behavior.
- For sure, yeah.
And the last question is,
I guess this could be for you,
but it's just sort of in general,
I guess I think dogs are really important,
and I think dogs have been around
for what, about 30,000 years,
living with hominids,
and they do seem to have been
an extraordinarily powerful tool,
at least for scavenging and
for safety and so forth,
and I bet that they do provide
a kind of cultural evolution
that has served us really quite well,
I really wanted to have dogs in this talk,
I mean in this meeting,
but there wasn't room,
so okay, thank you.
- So I'd like to thank Pat
Churchland and Tim White
for this fantastic symposium,
and of course all the speakers,
stay tuned for dogs,
the dogs and the wolves
will come back one day,
I promise.
And of course I'd like to
thank the audience here,
and the audience watching the webcast,
I look forward to seeing
you at the next symposium.
Thanks very much for
the supporters as well,
as well as the team
that made this possible,
the audiovisual team,
so with that I thank you again,
and I look forward to seeing you again,
have a wonderful evening.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)